- [Narrator] Austin asks,
"Gary, in episode 63,
"you say you watch and can tell
"if people are hustling.
"How do you tell?
"Engagement, frequency, or gut?"
- Austin, this a great question.
I love the recall
to that long long long time
ago episode, number 63.
Yeah, I mean this is how
I do it, and it's funny.
I'm in love with this answer, and like,
you know it's funny.
By the way, I'm giving you a pre-alert
that I think the answers on this show
are gonna be really good.
I feel up for today's answer.
I'm gonna go even deeper.
I remember why I started
this show, which is,
can I go deeper on all my quotes
for my fans?
I'm gonna challenge myself in this episode
to go deeper.
Both in the tactical aspects,
and the theoretical aspects.
And what I mean by that,
"Cloud and Dirt" by the way.
What I mean by that is,
how do I figure that out,
is very simple.
It starts with the fact
that I put in work.
So, when I go look at
your Twitter account,
and your Instagram account,
I will actually click your posts.
I will actually look at all your posts.
I go to everybody's.
If you go to a Twitter account,
you can hit their profile,
and then you can say view
all with replies, right?
So if you go on my account,
twitter.com/garyvee, you'll
see all my non-reply tweets.
And you'll be like, "Oh, Gary's
pushing out a lot of stuff."
But if you click with
replies, all of a sudden
you get a much deeper picture
into what I'm actually doing on Twitter,
which is I'm engaging at
scale with my community.
So, when I get pissed at all of you,
one of the things I'm
looking at is I'm like,
"Oh, look at all these 15 people
"that I just spent the last
35 minutes looking at."
When I click their Twitter account,
'cause they just engaged with me,
I'm double-checking so I
just click very quickly,
usually on my phone.
Oh, OK. Cool.
You say hello.
I mean let's do one right now.
Real time, baby.
Let's do one right now.
Very simple.
This is gonna be interesting.
Somebody's about to get
really called out, right?
So ya open a Twitter app, right?
And I go to my notifications,
and I don't know
what you're gonna get
here D-Rock, do your best
but I'll look, and I'll be like, you know,
social media twit, right,
you know, social media T-W-T-R.
This dude, right, he says he's been,
I asked "How long have
you been following me?"
A lot of you answered.
Thank you by the way.
Right, so I'll click
in, and I'll look at him
and I'll say OK, 1,080 and then I'll look
at what he's actually doing,
and I see he does a lot of retweeting.
OK, that's interesting to me, right?
He's doing a ton of retweeting
'cause that's his account.
So that gives me a sense
of what he's doing.
I'm gonna skip ahead 'cause
he's kind of playing that game.
Now, Christin will say,
"Great point by Gary Vee."
Thanks, Christin.
And I'll go into here and I'll
see she has 7,000 followers.
That'll give me some information.
And then I start looking
at what she's doing.
And then she's engaging, she's engaging,
she's engaging.
Here, she's retweeting.
She's hitting that person up.
I love this, hey, saying to somebody
they love the new profile picture.
This is starting to give me a sense,
and actually, Christin,
let's give her some daps.
Can you zoom in top-right corner.
Are you able to do something there
to give her some daps
so she gets some peep love?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So she's doing a good
solid amount of engaging.
She's doing some nice, solid retweeting.
She's actually really engaging.
Oh, crap!
Like, I don't know why I
didn't wanna curse there.
If you look now, go over here, D-Rock.
This is very faint,
but you can see there--
- Bring it up.
- Bring it up? Sure.
- All the way on the right where it says
one hour, one hour, two hours?
Can you see that on the right here?
It's very small but what I'm seeing is
that she's, I mean this is all happening
in the last two hours, a lot.
Heavy engagement.
She's crushing the engagement there.
So then the next thing I'll do,
I mean this is work.
Like, if anybody understands
like how do I know?
'Cause I'm putting in the work.
Next thing I do is I hit her URL
on her Twitter account
which is radical.social.
Right, and then this pops up.
And now I'm looking at this.
Is this her blog?
Is this where she works?
I don't know yet, but
here we're about to look.
OK, now I'm looking, and
I'm like do you know,
there are tons, and I'm
like "what is this?"
I'm trying to figure it out
and sometimes if I don't
figure it out quickly,
and I'm like "I don't know
what this is, I'm out."
Looks like her blog like, talk to me like,
you know like, oh this
is hitting up Chris.
Anyway, these are the things I'm doing.
I'm analyzing, right?
I'm looking at the other things you do.
If I was looking in my Instagram,
I'd look at the pictures.
What does that person put out?
What I'm seeing, my friends,
and the reason I called
out so many people,
is one, I'm seeing the
far majority of people
only in the right hook business.
Right?
Thanks to Christin
here, I'm in a good mood
'cause she's jabbing the shit out of it.
Right, so that's great.
But then there's other things.
Is she throwing right hooks?
Is she trying to drive people?
Like, 'cause the right hook
is part of the jab jab jab right hook,
which is the overall thesis.
Put out great content,
create value up front,
convert it into business.
And so when I see people,
and I see a lot of you
asking the same questions
about your coffee business,
your catering business,
all this, I'm trying to see
if you're doing that mix.
Are you only right hooking?
Are you only jabbing?
Are you driving people successfully.
Is your website responsive?
'Cause it's a mobile world.
These are like, I do this, and like
as you can see that alone.
I'm not even done with
Christin like auditing.
That alone is five, seven, nine minutes.
That's insanity in a
world where I'm so busy,
but that is the reason
so many of you follow me.
I truly believe that.
I believe in this karma,
zen kind of aspect to it
that I'm capable of giving
great answers on this show
'cause I know you way
better than you think.
In a world where every
one of my contemporaries
that's at my level, whatever that is,
thinks that the last three
minutes of this show,
the things that I do with my time.
In a world where, in my inbox, I mean.
Let's break this down.
Let's understand what I'm talking about.
In a world where I've got
all these e-mails right now,
and like going back, some of my clients
are gonna get upset here I think.
But like, here's a very
important e-mail from John,
the lead developer at Wine Library
about a new program we're about to launch
at winelibrary.com, from Friday.
Not answered yet.
Right?
Because I'm looking at
Christin's Twitter account.
Nobody, no businessperson thinks that's
the right move.
None.
And so I think if you wanna pop,
if you wanna be an anomaly,
you've gotta act like one.
(instrumental hip-hop music)